il faut rendre compte que il faut être
juste avec le gouvernement c'est quand
même 15 ans de politique militaire qu'il
faut mettre en cause parce que on a
toujours fait de l'instrument militaire
l'ajustement de nos politiques
budgétaires
donc forcément on est arrivé à un point
de rupture et c'est pas pour rien que le
général de villiers a démissionné
donc il ya tout à reconstruire et c'est
vrai que même si sentinelles à des
aspects psychologiques
extraordinairement rassurant il est vrai
aussi qu'ils sont aussi aux jeunes quand
on va à la messe de minuit à notre-dame
et qu on entre là travers effectivement
des soldats qui sont là avec les
mitraillettes
on est on est on l'aurait plein de
gratitude mais en même temps on se dit
c'est pas une société idéale
et même quand on leur risque un joyeux
noël on voit bien qu'ils sont
effectivement tendue et que c'est pas le
moment de le redire donc voilà ce sont
des choses sans les complexes